أنا أبي تشاي ليفي سوب Lp tsd نعم حسنًا
لقد شاركت في عدة حروب
عروض خاصة وأسمع هذه السيدة الكريمة
قول أشياء غير صحيحة وسأشرحها لك
أنت تتحدث هنا عن الأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة الجدد
في هذه الأثناء، المعاقين الذين يجلسون هنا ومسيرات أخرى
منحل منحل أنا أتحدث عني طيب عني
هذا
منحل وآسف أن أقول ذلك بطريقة ما
مثل هذا الطفرة بهذه الطريقة التي يتم بها بناء الشخص
العقلية موجودة على كل من من المفترض أن يعتني بك
مثال أصبحت مدمنًا على الكحول
أصبحت فقيرا
أنا فقير في الديون المذكورة أعلاه
من 800 إلى الكيس أنا منحني من كل الاتجاهات
كدت أن أقتل هذه المرأة عدة مرات
في يدي من النوم أتبول في الليل أنا
أخشى أنني لا أنام في الغرفة إذا لم أشرب الخمر
زجاجة فقط في اليوم الذي لا أستيقظ فيه من النوم لا أستيقظ
ليس هناك طريقة للنوم، أنت تتحدث معي، أنا آسف
خذها عليك، لكنك تتحدث معي
سنة ونصف في انتظار سيارة الخدمة لمدة سنة ونصف
للحصول على قرض لسداد الديون لماذا أحتاج
هل الإفلاس الإفلاس من المفترض أن أفعله
التسول لمدة عام ونصف هنا آدا تنتظر سنة ونصف
60 شيكل للإفلاس لماذا لا تأخذها
وهذه المسؤولية سيتحملها كل واحد منكم
أنا وهو وهو من كل القمامة التي دخلت إلي
في هذه الفترة التي أقاتل فيها كل يوم أتغلب عليه
أنا أتبول أثناء نومي ليلاً، هل تفهمين؟
إذا تحدثت معي عن أشخاص جدد، فسوف أفقد وعيي
في رأسي الآن، الآن أنا أتحدث إليكم
إطلاق النار آر بي جي أنا داخل القتال الدانماركي أنا في الداخل
دينيم رائحة القمر
أقوم بجمع الجثث في عيد المساخر بيدي
أين أنت طيب من هو الانتظار
لحظة
و